picking up where they left off from game
one on the offensive glass
20 rebound advantage overall and ingram
hits a twister off that baseline to give
new orleans an early two-zip lead
with crowder penetrating and working on
the column who just took it away
and the other way in full gallop mode
ingram takes it knifing his way in for
two
foul how about the long strides by
ingram
ingram will drive and detonate into the
paint and tap up and in on his own miss
ingram gets it to go and the lead for
the pelicans their biggest so far in the
very short life of this series up
torrey craig is on him he'll surge after
the screen and set up from 15. and think
about this
who he is seeing guard him started off
with crowder here number one overall
pick in the doncic and trey young draft
little zone here by the phoenix sun
ingram on the move and over powell a
ball and he got it to go
counted alan tunis has it
going through ingram knifing his way for
the basket boy oh boy he just sliced
right through the d
screen
switch feed
in the corner three ingram good got it
big three ingram who again is grimacing
as he goes the other way
it's payne
cameron johnson drives knocked away from
behind by marshall and how about the
physical play
will
[Applause]
the baseline inbound looking shot that
time by the high rising brandon ingram
into mcgee knocked away by ingram and
ahead to graham numbers
and engine tries to finish and does on a
great feed by ingram getting it from
devonta graham on that drive leading by
as many as nine trailing by eight
it's off to jones quick feed corner
three ingram got it
dance on the floor now for valencianas a
little bit more nimble going against
deandre ayton ingram with a long shot
it's a three and he kills it now clearly
they are running off the clock
approaching two shot clock at seven
[Music]
got it again